he is Eric Stonestreet the actor from
Modern Family he is also in a movie The
Secret Life of pets to its theaters June
7th modern family is coming to an end as
the sitcom has been renewed for an
eleventh and final season he's he's won
the Emmy he's been nominated for a
Golden Globe any kind enough to join us
on the program hi Eric
yep hey Dan good to see you sorry to be
here on such a dower day yeah so you
want a couple of these Emmy yeah two two
of them yeah but but I mean let's be
honest I do three hours live TV yeah you
do 22 minutes I don't need one 22
minutes I do about eight minutes yeah if
even then yeah yeah so you might be in a
couple of seams there yeah I'm in
virtually every scene for three out you
are in every scene you're writing it as
you're going yes I'm just delivering the
words of other people yeah they've come
up with yeah but it's great I loved
winning those two Emmys I'll tell you
yeah yeah I highly recommend really yeah
yeah you get the chance which you
haven't yet for this show I recommend
you winning it did you give a speech I
did I gave that speech yeah like what
who do you think I think my parents and
I told him I was gonna give it to them
and then I did okay yeah this is sincere
did you keep the second well I kept the
second one yeah I have the second one
where is it when I walk in to Eric
Stonestreet mansion yep do I know when
do I know what you do for a living when
I walk into your house ooh that's a
great question well not I mean my
winning a trophy for what you do is it's
a slippery slope because as you know
based on all this show that I've seen
today people desire to win Emmys and
when they don't they're not real super
stoked about it so my my feeling is I
won this Emmy I have to display it
somewhere but not like in your face
because if I don't if I put it in the
bathroom of the laundry room that's
disrespectful to other people yeah like
that would gladly win that at me like
you guys yeah you know so I have it on
my mantle and on my living room that I
never go into okay cuz it's a mansion
okay it is no it's not who do you live
live in I might be impressed with
Oh Keifer Sutherlands a neighbor across
the street okay yeah have you been
invited to parties over there yeah I
just was over there he walked by my
house and we happened to be out and he
was like come by I'm leaving town I'm
never in town come by and have a have a
drink so I was like Kiefer Sutherland
invites you over to have a cocktail you
go did you bring your Andy's the coolest
thing where I live in LA is Toluca Lake
and it's just an old school neighborhood
but across the street from me is the
original property that Roy and Walt
Disney owned and started selling off to
finance Walt Disney Studios yeah anyway
cool story I know yeah
anybody else interesting around you oh
let's see I mean the Disney story didn't
really yeah yeah so any interesting
people besides key for southern Melissa
McCarthy Steve Carell Oh Patricia Heaton
Oh Octavia Spencer II what do you want
me to do you want me to keep going no
it's pretty pretty good yeah
J my neighbor Jay Goldberg okay great
guy yeah James Trudy uh is Matt Walsh in
you're Matt Walsh isn't it in my name
yeah man I thought so have you been over
to Matt's house no no yet didn't invite
me but he just told me where he lives oh
yeah you come over here last week he's a
great guy he's a he's a great guy
have you guys ever had a material on
Modern Family where you said we can't do
that
mmm the kibosh because it's network TV
yeah well we've shot things that didn't
make the cut because standards and
practices probably jumped in and said no
thank you
and did you know at the time I yeah it's
pretty crazy they had I can't remember
the the perspective of like how it fit
but it was a flashback of me dressed
full on Native American crying remember
the commercial yeah a Native American
cried because of littering it was a you
know semaj homage to that but at some
point they realize like probably
shouldn't do that mmm it got cut out of
the episode
did you agree yeah because everybody's
gets canceled you know so you got a got
a bout of the the the the mob the
culture you know the when did you guys
know you were successful I would say I
knew when Ed O'Neill called me and said
if this shows not on for ten years I
don't know what the hell I'm doing in
this business I trusted he would know
that so I knew we were good shot and
then once we got nominated for Emmys
that first year and won all of them how
this is awkward
yes really from your on a bad day let me
celebrate your celebrate so happy for
you
I really am I really am happy for you
I'm fine you happy you got a couple
breaks here yeah anywho yeah I could
tell that Disney story again yeah yeah
that killed last time when you do so
you're in the the animated secret life
of pets too but I saw where Harrison
Ford is yeah he is okay do you do you
get to see Harrison Ford no no no okay
but we don't get to see each other in
the boat you don't know we're not we're
never in the booth together I'd yeah
is that how hard is that well you're do
you do it every day yeah talk to you you
know you have these people to talk to
but you're also essentially or answering
talking and answering your own questions
yes regularly but you gotta you have to
garner you know muster up a motion to in
certain situations for the role don't
you yeah sometimes and you have to do it
in weird like you have to grunt
emotionally oh you know or whatever it
is like sad you have to eat sad or what
you know those are the hard things and
what's your character Duke Duke Duke the
dog because a big dog and then in your
mind do you become a dog yeah I think so
I think once I got the part I
immediately was just you know thinking
that way for sure you know you just kind
of start to lift your leg and yeah just
walk by
I feel like you yeah I like that what
are you gonna do after Modern Family's
done man I don't know but I love what
you do I'm not I told you before when
I'm yes with you before that I'll uh I
loved just chatting about stuff and
having you know good time talking about
things that I'm interested in so this
area is definitely something I'm
interested but I have no idea what
people are gonna want me to do like
maybe they will just be tired of me
which I'm okay with it's only 22 minutes
a week eight about eight minutes do you
think you could do three hours each day
where you just chop things up I'd need
help yeah cuz it it's people always say
oh boy what a luxury to do three hours
no man they get about 17 minutes in it
they go oh my god the hardest thing I
was just saying back there would be for
me coming off like a family show is to
find you know the the courage to be
opinionated and say what I really want
to say because you you get you get to do
that and I know that sometimes that gets
everybody you know so I admire I admire
that and it was one of the harder things
even though I had strong opinions I when
I did SportsCenter my job was not to
give opinions right my job was just to
give you the highlights and then do
stories and then you do this then you
have to have an opinion and the
dangerous part is people feel like you
have to have a hot take on every yeah
and there are times when I go I'd like
to do a little homework on this yeah I'd
like to do a little research I I'm not
comfortable saying this is how I feel
now my initial reaction which is subject
to change is this but a lot of guys get
out in front of something and then they
have to walk it back
yeah I mean you're a jerk you're a
journalist like you know so it makes
sense that you would want to like take a
look at things and decide what what what
your opinion is before you're put on it
and then roasted for it you know who
would you have is your co-host oh wow
anybody I don't I'd see I don't know
what the format of my what if I had a
show like this what it would be because
I would want to talk about a range of
topics not just sports because again I'm
not as knowledgeable with all sports as
I
would need to be mad walsh might be
pretty good Matt Matt Matt's great yeah
IIIi would need somebody just to you
know somebody funny funnier than me yeah
you know which shouldn't be hard to find
but somebody that Chetwood would
challenge me I'm having a hard time with
this chair yeah I know microphone I
can't put my my host would be was win an
Emmy we're gonna get a better a better
chair yeah better better chair I was
also gonna ask you with the Kansas City
Chiefs
yeah go ahead yeah so sorry about that
what about sorry about what I'm sorry
yeah you guys you guys lost oh well yes
last year we look to the future see okay
but if I said you could give up your
Emmys hmm and the Chiefs get the ball in
overtime you oh you've got to give up
your Emmys you just get the ball in
overtime okay there's a very distinct
clarification I need to make do I give
up the honor of winning an Emmy or just
the trophy you give up the trophies oh
I'll give up the trophies to further
ball in overtime okay
trophies are trophies okay you give up
the honor of having going on stage
points yeah I probably wouldn't do that
because I believe in Patrick mahomes and
I believe we're gonna do it again so I
think we're in the towel painful was
that dainty Ford it was really really
painful it was really it was painful now
you know how I felt last night no that's
how much it hurt no yeah no yeah I don't
believe that for a minute I believe you
have the exact right attitude on this
Emmy stuff how devastated was Eric we
went out to dinner last night and danced
at there staring at his plate for two
hours and see tonight the other guys
were trying to make pithy jokes to keep
the mood up and they were playing like
sad bastard music at the restaurant it
was a disaster yeah gosh Dan yeah I
really feel bad for kind of making fun
of you now yeah yeah well hey listen you
know the modern family like where would
I fit in if I was in Modern Family oh
one of Jays friends at the club okay
well I'd like to get in the house yeah
but well you'd come over for maybe visit
but you just BJ's friend would I have a
girlfriend
sure wife probably why yeah you'd have a
wife or something like that
have you tried to get my home zone
the show no I haven't tried to get my
homes on the show we had George Brett
they wrote a part for George Brett and
did you play a role in getting George
Brett I texted him and said hey do you
want to be a one-one family I mean and
he wrote back let me check my schedule
and then he wrote back immediately yeah
I'm in yeah he was super stoked to be
there at Patrick mahomes unmodern it
would have to I mean it would have to be
story generated but I I mean I would
love for Patrick mahomes to be on but
yeah his time is just starting my my
little run on Modern Family is over how
exciting are my like look can we just
discuss the Chiefs I don't I think I
think white people are kind of over
rating your Chiefs this year for real
yeah I love this I do I'm worried about
Tyreke you I I'm worried about the
running back situation okay you got a
great tight end but I don't know how
good the defense is Spags is there young
new defense and it made a lot I'm just
we're better than last year because let
me tell you Tyrann Mathieu playing is
better than Eric Berry not playing okay
if the Patriots played the Chiefs right
now we would win in New England we oh
okay well okay I don't even think you're
better than the Chargers Wow i I'm glad
you didn't win the Emmy yeah no I but
this is how I get nominated yeah yummy
with takes like that yeah yeah I think
you're I think you're wrong I I think
the Chiefs we have we have improved our
teams so Moe do you want to bet you and
I personally yeah we can say on the air
what dan gets a extra role on Modern
Family or you get to host the show well
I mean gotta forum you got come on
you've won a couple of Emmys yeah but I
can't promise anything on my show it's
your show I'm an actor so I I do have an
IMDB yeah but I wouldn't feel
comfortable having Dan Patrick on Modern
Family with no lines and I can't promise
you lions on a network television show
as great as you are hmm
okay you know what are you being on what
about cash how about how about dinner
okay yeah I would I mean that'd be an
honor I'd be here with you
but I roll really deep because if if if
you bring me then it's no you know the
the place you know that plays five guys
that's not the restaurant I'm talking
about here these are the five guys right
here you go to go to dinner now if you
want to bring somebody yeah you can if
if if I lose I think it would be amazing
right now to make a bet that if well
what are we betting first of all that
the Chiefs beat the Chargers who is who
goes farther Chiefs XI I know that o
Chiefs are the Chargers Chiefs
okay I got the Chargers going farther
for a role on Modern Family and then
whoever picks up I just want to be part
of a winner for a change
yeah well weird where it has been they
don't think they like the shiny stuff
man we're in art 11 maybe since you're
bringing four people Eric you can bring
forth like you bring like Lake Bell and
okay inappropriate all of your other
levers wait I mean he's asking for me to
bring a married woman to dinner Kevin
Hart I'm saying like your other cast
members I'm not see more along the lines
of Patrick mahomes and Travis Kelce so
they can stare at you the whole game
okay the whole dinner all right
it'd be like good good good take Dan way
to go Dan that was awesome Dan I wish
you a lot of luck in success Eric in the
secret life of pets too you know I don't
June 7th but I do love Modern Family
well I appreciate that I do love Modern
Family I think it's it's it's you know
when you look at something that lasts
that long but it involves and then you
have different characters and they allow
you to volve I think that that's what's
great you didn't stay with a one-trick
with it no there are always so many
great stories coming up with new stuff
and doing different things and I think
the seat our our final season will we're
not there's not gonna be any petitions
to read no no dying nobody dies doing I
don't I don't think we can kill anybody
we got to stay away from that the the
movie he's reprising his role as the mut
Dooku secret life of pets
he's Eric Stonestreet he's won a couple
of Emmys ha and it's the eleventh and
final season of Modern Family we are
back after this on the Dan Patrick show
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show at
[Music]